what I want us to think about is this
perception actually learned about
expanding in fact arises before we've
done it quite a few times but maybe you
don't understand why we do it so I
usually take a step back I'm not going
to assume you're experts at this even if
you've seen it before so expanding and
factored energy but look at these one at
a time the first thing to know is that
the reason why we have these together is
that these are two sides of the state
coin right these are opposites if
something is factorized then you can
expand it and if something is already
expanded you can satirize it so these
are really doing one operation ordering
it in reverse and that's why we speak of
them together let's start with the first
one expanding if I show you something
like this you've had to deal with these
without algebraic fractions right so you
know you how to do this I can expand
this I can expand it in fact I'm even
going to put it inside this box right AG
what would it mean to expand this what
would you get the answer I don't five
eight ten right now I want you to think
you're quite good at doing this now
especially with simple examples like
this you're sitting down with a year
seven or eight student and they've never
seen this before
you can explain like how to do it like
where the fire comes from or where the
tent comes from but what you're actually
doing like what's the difference between
left and right probably what most of you
would say is expanding looks like get
rid of the brackets
how did you get rid of the brackets what
did you do for example by over the - in
what way did you combine them if you
multiply them so you get rid of brackets
by multiplying that's what it looks like
okay why do we do it why is this useful
think back even to question one in the
review that you did today you did some
expanding you did it twice
in fact on top of those radicals why did
you do it look at the line where you did
it what was better about it afterwards
factorized versus before ii thought this
is a hard question there's not a simple
question to think about it why do we
expend yeah if we want to get rid of
some terms right simplify beings I think
if you have a look at you're working
immediately after expanding you
collected like terms didn't you right so
why do we do it it makes it easier to
collect like terms this is not the only
figure dollars but for now this is the
thing we're primarily interested in so
you have to write this down but if the
question was five times a plus two minus
three a well it's fun expanding gives
you a clear advantage it doesn't it
because once you've done that you can
say oh I can put those like terms
together and I will get something and
take ten which is simpler than what I
had before so far so good okay so we
understand its meaning can you explain
factorizing this if I told you from the
beginning that these are opposites to
each other two sides of the same coin
and this is the way we've worded it's
baby
how would you would factorize you or
your bracket by
I'm going to stop by any records I think
it's a great way to start because if
we're getting rid of bankers before if
you factorize you have rackets where you
didn't have them but how do I do that
okay by now this is why we call it
factorizing right we want to identify
comment factors and you should that's it
please emphasize that that's the ideas
right so you get sterilized almost
anything right we're looking at algebra
at the moment but you can even
factorizing numbers for years 24 is a
number and you can factorize it in lots
of ways can someone give me two double
switches for another three and three
twelve to twenty-four one okay you've
identified factors in there but when
you're factorizing with algebra we're
looking for common factors okay now you
don't need to write another example this
because you already have there it is
right side out plus 10 you identify the
corner that cell which in this case was
five and then you can take it out and a
brand does that make sense
okay again this is the last question why
do you do it what advantage is there so
factorizing why is factorize you mixing
English sometimes let me give you an
example a little bit off this one that
we just tell look at 5 a + 10 here's
something that's expanded and you may
want to factorize it here might be a
case where factorizing is useful
now in this case to make things simpler
it will be easier to do that it's easier
to work out how to make it simpler if
this topic is factorize
we already know what the factorization
is so how do you suppose them declare
their focus is hurt swollen
ah so what you've seen is by pulling out
common factors if there are common
factors in other places then you can see
the bug map like there are here so you
would say there's a fine here if you
take that out you get up to the tenth
and this is objectively better than what
we started if you agree though because
do you appreciate different ocular ones
so I will point out if you're if you're
pretty cruelly we'd like to know does it
all I kind of think you can see a
question basically like there's nothing
wrong with going straight there you
don't have to factorize but number one I
know about you I don't see things like
that straight away I have to have this
additional step number two I'm going to
give you stuff way more complicated than
this and you're going to encounter
things where it's just not obvious at
all or even if it's obvious I need you
to show me I need you to communicate
that you know where they were from
okay um sometimes particular year eleven
and twelve you've got a question it says
like actually give you the answer they
give you this they know where you're
going to end up to the oppression is not
about finding an answer the question is
about showing how you got there show you
the process and factorize it helps them
however you to wear this we expand
because it makes it easier to collect
like terms I would suggest we factorize
because what what it allows to do here
it enables up to
cancel or simplify factors we've seen it
in algebraic fractions because carefully
happens with what factors that make them
easier to work with but there are lots
of other cases too
do you remember again turn to the back
of the room see how there's that poster
about calculus right customers when
you're working with calculus it is
sometimes you really really important
see that massive letters right all those
processes that a lot of you are going to
learn next year the year after that you
can take back to the front now those
processes are so much easier sometimes
if things are back to right okay we
don't know what this processes are so I
thought right through here yet ready for
one-to-one you can say also calculus and
next year when you learn is I heard that
Victor tag or membership ah this is why
we had to spend so much time factorizing
regret it because calculus relies on
actually both of this you can tell which
operation you need to do even with that
theme the question because if you
remember what expansion factor is are
like which what bless you what they do
in relation to bracket what do you ask
to do with this get rid of the minute so
let's remove them the way that we remove
them is by multiplying
okay so I'm going to do it one at a time
first carry be careful student numbers
then will be produce so negative persons
5 is 25
okay you can see now why we also
invented some typing using the index
laws earlier last week you need to sort
of be able to do this a bit you know on
autopilot not think too hard x times x
squared cubed fantastic first term is
done now I'm going to multiply through
the next one always watch outside
negative it is the most common area to
make with all of these negative five
times four is twenty and then you look
at the pretty broad
ex-wife that wasn't complicated okay
generally people find you standing much
easier to do because multiplying you can
do it somewhat mindlessly
factorize eager include this skill
to look and see so have a look at
question five now again even without
being told the word for the question you
can see this is going to be a factorize
question not expand because there are no
brackets it's already expanded so I'm
going to add some in okay I want to look
for what are the common factors between
the things that are there okay let's
just do it
Isis loaded someone said to six and 10
are both even numbers so let's just pull
that - okay there's no reason why you
have to do all of these one here so
we'll just do it gradually it's like
when you take the two out you're going
to divide this by 2 and this point - its
division because the opposite of
expanding which is multiplication so
what are we left when you divide by 2 I
haven't done anything with the negative
so it's still there do you agree
like I haven't pulled the negative sign
out of you divide this by 2 by C square
I haven't done anything to the teaser
distal there so this happened frequently
you factorize various factorize by the
way but I can factorize further
what else can I take up okay so teens
also call it so there's already two
there now I'm also going to take the
tear
what does it be factorized - three
what's left of you then you look again
is there anything else I can tweet
others
you can't tweet the negative out I could
make this - two team that would change
to a 3 - 5 t that would be fine I could
just as easily just change this order
right I could leave it a 2 T and then
just go 5 t minus 3 there's not really
any clear advantage to either of those
if you saw this on time in the back of
the book and you had this on top of your
page
those are both fine here's why what is
this question about it's like expanding
your factorizing these are push back
drives to the same notes we take
statements pop out so these were ready
okay